[Musik]
[Applaus]
Vormundschaftsbehörde hab mir Zeit ich
in es schöns
Mädchenheim mit gich ALG me und ich mit
de auswärts geschaffe in der Spinnerei
und Verdi m eig Geld und ich habefunden
ja als Heimkind sch du kein Recht D mach
scht
[Musik]
das B 18ch wde hab ich das Bedürfnis geh
wieder mal meine Mut gesehen sie sehr
sehr wenig
gesehen nichts ahnend
fr dankt meine Mutter mich geholen und
wer ST am B
Seif vom
Fürsorge Wald nicht meh
verstanden undit
elfried du g nicht zck du jetzt mit dem
Zug
[Musik]
dir
vormundschaftsfrau sie h währ der ganze
Reise kein Ton mit mir n
[Musik]
als die jungen Frauen in dirtfurt im
tockenburg ankamen hatten sie keine
Ahnung was sie
erwartet
[Musik]
in der Spinnerei sollten Sie für den
damals reichsten Mann der Schweiz
[Musik]
arbeiten für Emil bürle waffenfabrikant
kriegsprofiteur und
[Musik]
Kunstsammler
und wo wir auch sind sfurtin
F und dann hab ich dankt wow aber nicht
schon
wiederlerfau die machten ich seh ein
sers Schlag s B
SM ich hab sachent ich nicht
viel strerin hat mir den der spießsal
zeiget W ich der riesig spießsal geseh
wo mindestens 100 Personen
Platz denkt
l jetzt bist wieder im Heim
gandet das Marienheim es wurde von
ingenboher Schwestern geleitet und
gehörte Emil bürle heute ist es ein
Wohnhaus von der ehemaligen Spinnerei
ist es nur wenige Meter
entfernt vor 65 Jahren stand Irma frei
zum ersten Mal vor dieser
Tür
so willkommen im Hus danke ich positive
[Musik]
Gedanke Fritz Rutz der Hausbesitzer
führt Irma frei durchs
[Musik]
Haus wenn wir da in sind haben wir m
dort Schuhe Wechsel ja ja ja da haben
wir ja
meint
ja
ja es stimmt so genau wie wenn in das
Loch hin Lauf es kommt alles
wieder und sie sind
insgesamt ja
korrekt ich habe mir vorgestellt dass S
große Pension und
da
dasin hat den
IR
Gang rum zu den
DR und die H mir gesag du mus morgen am
vi
und spinchicht schaffen und dann ich
gagt
wie und dann h gesagt du immer mach kein
hoffn
dast du n bevor du 20 bist das ist
gerade noch
heav das hab ich nicht
erwartet wer ins Marienheim kam hatte
meist schon Schlimmes hinter sich Irma
frei wuchs in Schafhausen auf die
Familie war bitter
arm
der Vater alkoholkrank manchmal
gewalttätig sich ter sch und dann
istmschaft
[Musik]
und und dann hat man mich wier
abgeschendorf
und das ist ganz ganz schlimm mit
sieie das
Kinderheim das hat über 200
Kinder und ich V ingber schwö geführt
wurde und ist mottoxie Zucht und
[Musik]
Ordnung
meine Mutter hat mir mit
mal git ich hätte dich eigentlich müs
abrieben mir das
anvertraut meine Mutter ist mit dem mit
mir mit dem vierte Kind schwanger worden
dann hab wir im Fürsorge Gag das kom
jetzt nicht frag das gibt's nicht das
mebe fertig Schluss und so git ganz
schlimme repressorie für Sie und für
Kind und hat trot und dann hat sie mich
geboren in der
Frauenklinik
und am gleichen Tag weg vor der Mutter
ist
Heim was das für ein verlus für beide
das ich mir auch Hute
no bewusst und ich bin dann V da bin ich
heimerie immer Heimer
das ist es macht mich truhrig wenn ich
der V
Rede eine Kopie der fürsorgeakten aus
dem Staatsarchiv
Schwiz unter keinen Umständen will
Carmen scheiwier dass jemand diese Akten
liest sie war ein Jahr alt die ins
Kinderheim Einsiedeln steckte es hat
schon menfangen also Mittwoch z.B hab
freiol frei Mittag oder mir müssen in
luftschutzer aber hat zwei große lange
Tisch so höchb mit
herdöpfel B h tich mü herdöpfel spit und
bis bis fertig sie wir immer
rosanz dass
man und dann sind die herdöpfel hat so
große
Ferin Wasser dr oder also am Mittwoch
und die m he bis andere Mitwoch aber das
Wasser ist niet worden und bis am
Schluss h schwarze herdöpfel gesse und
das ist so
gr sie sich gar nicht vorstellen
alle heimstationen von Carmen scher sind
in ihren Akten vermerkt bis zur
Volljährigkeit damals mit
20 aber das was sie wirklich erleiden
musste steht nicht
[Musik]
drin wir
sind Zimmer oder und ich w im Gang hier
und Herf mit dem gebbür Bet und dann ich
mal Zimmer
aufet und irgendwo hat sie B
herleit
irgendwi Deck
auflopft und wenn du kalt kalt im Zimmer
als Kind
do knchen und zwischen kN
W WN sie das gesehen hat dann B ich
abgeschlagen worden aber richtig
abgeschlagen und den H nachher no mü ist
Badzimmer der hat Dr badw und eine ich
immer gefüll mit Wasser da du mü in die
badwanen in Sitz und da hat sie dich
abunkt da ich auch mal mü ich ich ich
alle aber ich kann ganz sicher aber da g
ich mache schon W ich will dass sie die
am Hals genau so hinen abruckt bis re
gurgelt hat d h
wiederön und Sommer oder Winter s hast
du m nachher das Kal immer wieder
h sag die hät das nicht glaubt oder und
dann wär es wieder wieder
zurück es ist sch
Sch
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Irma frei war 17 als sie ins Marienheim
geschickt
[Musik]
wurde
am hat der Maschinenmeister
[Musik]
maschinenestellt die pföte sind alle
original die sind vorher
brunxi das sind
mindestens 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 na Maschine
sind da gestanden alles die giche da hat
man eine Maschine nach der andere
gemacht oder also du hast
bestandig da h du die lepurle da nimmst
du Flügel leichchen Herren und nimmst
die vol Spur und die leer wieder
in du hast immer M L dass die lauf lauf
laufet du h pauseön schalten es ist
trostlos trostlos schwer St am Morgen
um lärmig und stinkig und H mü liefere
liefere und wenn du nicht ein Star e
will h den G du unter und
derfall der hab ich ih nicht gemacht hab
ich ih nicht
gemt
[Musik]
so
Elfi grendene war verheiratet ist Mutter
von drei Kindern und hat zwei
Enkelkinder eine Familie wie sie es sich
immer gewünscht
hat sie hat ein antiquitäengeschäft
geführt und war als betagtenpflegerin
tätig
eig mit normal aber das geh lang da
vorher
vorbereitet
unabhängigkeitch Ziel immer das RO Vater
hat sich dazogen undute ich muss sagen
ich weiß schon was
[Gelächter]
ich
7 und
[Musik]
dann F wie Beers
frraau
so vor über Z Jahren hat
grendene einen politischen Prozess
angestoßen mit dem niemand gerechnet
hatte
[Musik]
angefangen hat alles mit dem zircher
Kunsthaus hier der Erweiterungsbau mit
der Sammlung Emil bürle ein
milliardenschatz und höchst umstritten
seit Jahren diskutieren Historikerinnen
und kunstsachverständige über die
Herkunft bestimmter
Bilder ebenso umstritten der Sammler
bürle der deutsche der 1937 die
Schweizer Staatsbürgerschaft erlangte
macht er aus der werkzeugmaschinenfabrik
earlycon ein florierendes Unternehmen
und produzierte im großen Stil Waffen
der rüstungsindustrielle lieferte seine
Waffen im Zweiten Weltkrieg an Nazi
Deutschland und die
Achsenmächte das machte ihn zum
reichsten Mann der Schweiz ich viel
Klasse zietige hab mich da immer verdüft
[Musik]
hat der schlagdusch geseh zwischen der
linke und der züritig das Hin und Her
mit der Waffe mit der
Bildergeschichte aber was da der Schwiz
eigentlich abgegangen ist das ist immer
schön Jahre lang einfach unterm Deckel
blieben und da hab ich einfach da hat
langsam Br mir Gefühl hallo ne got
einfach
nicht sie geht mit ihrer Geschichte zur
Zeitschrift
Beobachter der Beobachter berichtet das
erste Mal über die Zwangsarbeiterinnen
im Marienheim und über die
Textilfabriken von Emil
[Musik]
bürle
alles lie
g ist unterwegs mit der
ehemaligener Gemeinderätin Christin
seler von Seidler der Vorstoß verlangt
die Stadt Zürich solle die Rolle der
fürsorgebehörden aufarbeiten und einen
Solidaritätsbeitrag Zahlen es berührt
mich
wirklich nein und ich find sie sch es
ist Höch Zeit ja ich bin dankbar dass
ich darf
da für die viele vielen opfero irgendwo
s stellvertr
aber bin ich immer g ja ja
ja ich bin wirklich froh und dankbar
dass man z regier nach langem zögeren
und nach
langem sch ist ernst sich dem Thema
auseinanders und das ist krasses Thema
und da ger
her
Zürich hauptbahnh
[Musik]
n du hast den immer s
Maschine g
das D sind wirammen undag ich h schn ist
schnellert wenn du aber
bist mit Memen den ist ab und zu d z.B
ein Vater Griss hat und dann hat ganze
Reihe einfach putzt und das ist schlimm
durch das hast Du natürlich den Z
Laufmeter auf der Maschine und das man
entweder ist spinnereibüro oder ist Büro
ist marieim was dann wieder verbunden
ist du hast meh Arbeit
oder am Sonntag ist dir der Spaziergang
Strich
worden es war das Highlight der Woche vi
Stunden Ausgang am Sonntag Nachmittag es
hat e doch
irgendwie zeig so ist es
W
her Kaffe in Sitz normale andere l
junge das bisschen Freiheit darf nicht
darüber
hinwegtäuschen die Frauen waren nicht
freiwillig in dirtfurt und dies ohne
Gerichtsurteil mindestens 300 junge
Zwangsarbeiterinnen waren in den 1940er
50er und 60er Jahren im Marienheim und
mussten für Emil bürle später für seinen
Sohn Dieter in den Textilfabriken
arbeiten dirtfurt war aber kein
Einzelfall in der ganzen Schweiz haben
fürsorgerämter junge Frauen in Fabriken
gesteckt
dabei war Zwangsarbeit seit 1941 in der
Schweiz offiziell
verboten die jungen Frauen waren der
Fürsorgebehörde völlig
ausgeliefert auch als die obligatorische
Schulzeit endete und die Mädchen aus den
Kinderheimen rauskamen die Fürsorge
bestimmte das Leben
weiterhin sie platzierte die Frauen bis
zu ihrer Volljährigkeit V
willkürlich bevor erm frei nach dirfurt
ins Marienheim geschickt wurde arbeitete
sie als
Haushaltshilfe ich bin der tero und ich
habe vom erste Tag gemerkt die Frau mag
mich nicht die immer
immer ich nicht richtig koch ich nicht
richtigemacht ich hab nicht sozt wie
sie in AK ich
denstanden sie müssen mich in die Fabrik
du will ich viel Pause mache und ich MSS
an andauerndes Arbeit gewöhnt werde ich
nicht stellig nicht so all den Vorwürfe
warum ich ist marieeim warum
mich warum die Frau reklamiert sie nicht
Schlag mit
mir
27 50 5
64 mit 14 kam Carmen schiwieler aus dem
Kinderheim Einsiedeln raus danach
arbeitete sie ein Jahr lang als
Putzkraft in einem
Spital ich bin
sofed so fr Patient mit mir gesw sind
und ich hat dürf Antwort gen oder das
ist für mich so schön gie und eines
Tages hat eine Zimmerkollegin von mir
Gig aber
sie Theater
auch mit und dann hab ich gesagt ja komm
mit da hat sie mir noch ein Lippenstift
zum
lippenstrechen
Z ja
pofer
und Schuhe also mit spacksle oder n Fall
das Theater ich fertig s den ich
dann Verg ich mir habe Michis gefragt
und hab ich gar nicht gewusst was der W
da sage ich so blöd das he ich
erlaubt was
das
ich
tan probier das ist das schon falsch
nach du du mus sachenmenpack du
anderort sie war 15 ein Mädchen noch als
sie die Fürsorge im Marienheim
platzierte siebeitete in
auch diese Fabrik gehört der Emil
bürle das
ist
spium die n l brat mus sag das das ist
im Mädchenhandel g der B hat
Arbeiterin brucht und die
Fürsorge ich danke
amtchwizeris hat sich da hat sich da
bedient und hat die me verbrachtt und
hat Kapital geschlagen muss sag brutal
aber so
g für die Fürsorge die billigste Lösung
sie war ihre mündell los und hatte kaum
mehr kosten die Maßnahme hieß Erziehung
zur
Arbeit Fabrikbesitzer wie Emil bürle ein
äußerst profitables
Geschäft die Spinnerei in
dirertfurt im Dorf nebenan in Bütschwil
die Weberei
Emil bürle kaufte die Fabriken 1941 von
deutschjüdischen Flüchtlingen zu einem
sehr niedrigen Preis die beiden
Textilfabriken waren für das ganze
tockenburg ein enormer
Wirtschaftsfaktor in Spitzen waren herte
Arbeiterinnen und Arbeiter hier
beschäftigt zu unterst in der Hierarchie
die
[Musik]
Zwangsarbeiterinnen wir hab nie Geld
über das ist Tab über das hat man nicht
Gert
und
sind hat mir
J wie viel das ich Verdi
J ich nie ein
lohnuswies oder monatsabrechn ich nicht
was ich verdien
ich irgend unterschrieben und ich kan im
Monat
Frank die Löhne flossen direkt ans
Marienheim mit dem G haben die
ordenschwestern
dasimfüh es
knapp Nötigste zu
decken so finanzierten die Frauen ihre
eigene
Wegsperrung das Kloster Ingenbohl in
Brunnen Kanton
Schwiz im Klosterarchiv lagern die
Chroniken vom Marienheim in
dirtfurt die ingenber Schwestern sollten
die jungen Frauen nach
Moralvorstellungen der katholischen
Kirche und der damaligen Gesellschaft
Formen der Monat Januar bringt uns acht
Schweizerinnen sie kommen von der
Vormundschaft die Mission ist klar
nämlich unseren Mädchen den Weg zu einem
reinen Leben
zeigen dabei helfen sollen Filme wie die
heilige von
lisieu die Ordensschwestern erwarten
absoluten Gehorsam und Schreiben von
Frauen die glauben mit Frechheiten die
Welt erobern zu
können von Mädchen die herausfordernd
sind und sich öfters nicht
fügen regelmäßig versuchen junge Frauen
zu fliehen eine 17-Jährige probiert
durch ein Fenster in der Stube zu
entkommen
ein Mädchen nimmt in bütchwil Reis
aus ein anderes flieht nach St
Gallen ich auch mal ein verholf
dazu ich bin mit der Spazier
siefagtst mit mir spazieren sag ja dann
SEAG sie du wei ich würte
ABG und dann hab ich Gag ja du wenn du
das W se ja ich w sag l mal wir machen
so wenn du W ich g jetzt da aufs WC GST
du einfach ich ich hab nicht gesehen und
denn bin ich hi da ich
SEAG W D span da ich gesagt ja ich will
müssen auf W und W ich
ich gesehen ich aber ich nicht W
verraten
oder der ingenboher Orden will sich
nicht äußern und nimmt zu Marienheim
keine
Stellung die Schwestern Teilen mit sie
hätten sich bereits mit ihrer
Vergangenheit in den Kinderheimen
auseinandergesetzt und sich vor 10
Jahren öffentlich
[Musik]
entschuldigt h wir jetzt auf die Spieß
nein das ist
rental geh spie das ist Spieß ist un
anschlüßend ja und Samstag sonag auch im
aufenthalum sie das ist schön W am
Sonntag dann haben wir 4
stundenusgang und das ist Highlight V
der
Woche abergang nur Kirchgang girchgang
ja das ist so g Sonntag morgen oh mein
Gott da haben wir jeden Sonntag murgen m
zweier Kolon vfurt auf bchwi laufen
[Musik]
K die drübank die sind jewiels immer für
meit im marieim reserviert und immer m
viertelstund bevor das die K sind
mü mir Religion überhaupt nicht bedeutet
ich eher als Stra empfunden wieder das
sein
Gut
se
wit das sind die gefall
me aber mir sind n die gefallen
nein bis G dass mir a sozialschwache
Verhaltnis
sind das
ist und nicht will mir gefallen e sie
sind und das H lü vom Dorf leider
[Musik]
nichtwüst das sind schwö strickte der G
dass
mir mit der bevölker Kontakt
[Musik]
Aufgen carmen scheiwier ist zweimal
verwitwet hat zwei Kinder fünf
Stiefkinder und zwei Enkel sie arbeitete
unter anderem als Geschäftsführerin
eines
Kaffes da vor jetzt
das
sie lebt nicht weit von derberei
entfernt wo sie als junges
mädchenarbeitet hat oft spert sie mit
ihrer stiechter am Fabrikareal
vorbei während über 20 Jahren war die
Textilindustrie aus bchwi verschwunden
heute produziert hier wier eine
webmanufaktur und stellt Küchen und
Geschirrtücher her
[Musik]
lange hat kamen schiwier nicht in der
Weberei
gearbeitet sonag und dann hat gei du mus
n die K h ich dank h n die K und
dann ja hat sie gesagt ne du musst in
die Sache packen dann sag sag die andere
Haus doch ab od s Abgang D ichesagt ja
du wo soll ich ich habe kein Mensch ich
habmer auf der Welt ich B
ganzi den men oder und den nach ist den
da einfach Hal polizis dass S mir da mit
dem Zug FT und dann seit
ich w W ich her sage
ich
ne aber ich ich Verm sch man hat
früh und
so ich ich w
in se ja da
ich zum Guten Hirten in Altstätten St
Gallen warum weiß sie bis heute
nicht in der geschlossenen Anstalt blieb
sie bis zu ihrer
[Musik]
Volljährigkeit
schön viele sind am Unrecht zeren WTE
brauch einen großen Willen und eine
strategieen ist einfach dass sie einfach
ein extreme Humor entwickelt glaub zum
das auch Spiele denke
einm also das sie einfach viel irgendwie
so ja ja ich bin
immerig
ja aber da h sie auch S über wasserkalte
und GLB mit dem
[Musik]
es ist einfach immer über dich bestimmt
wordde ich hab
einfachck wieso bin ich überhaupt sie
gemacht mal ich dank eigentlich so viel
wie andere bin ich doch auch
Wert von ist mir besser gegangen ich
habe wirklich an mir müssen schaffen
oder wä ich GUB h noch weiß auch nicht
wo das GT nur mit dem gesunde
Selbstwertgefühl und mit der würde wo
ich mir selber muss erarbeit vor allem
Eigenwert dass das mus sicherarbeit aber
das mus sich lieb machen das ist das ist
nur Liebe zu sich wo das
[Musik]
bringt das Zürcher Gemeindeparlament
tagt in der
[Musik]
bullingerkirche Christine Seidler und
Elfie grendene werden von
sozialvorsteher Rafael goter begrüßt
[Musik]
grü
ja
ich
und hab ich das H gest gefunden
morgenrotchen daäung Morgenrot ich das
[Gelächter]
ist
[Musik]
nervöse begrüße zu 40 Sitz vom
Gemeinderat von der Stadt sü gum verord
solidaritätsbitrag Opfer V
fürsorgerische Zwangsmaßnahme und
fremdplatzierige vor
1981 ich möchte vus schicken dass ich
vor einer betroffene Person das Rösel
und der Postkarte als danke schön dass
mir das da behandelt was ich
gern fremdplatzier und Zwangsmaßnahme Z
ih unkürlichkeit zu dunkelste Kapitel
von der Schwizer und der Zürcher
sozialgesch sieens von der Behörde und
auch das kam der Akten in näh ist zum
Teil unglaublich wird abschätzig über
die Mensche gese die Stadt Zürich stellt
sich der Debatte die bürleerben hingegen
wollen sich nicht äußern Gratian anda
hier links im Bild mit seiner
verstorbenen Mutter Hortense anda
bürle die Zeitschrift Bilanz schätzt das
Vermögen der Familie and der bürle auf 1
bis 1,5 Milliarden Franken der
54-Jährige anda einer der Enkel von Emil
bürle nimmt keine Stellung zum
Marienheim und zu den Textilfabriken
seines
[Musik]
Großvaters als der Beobachter die
Geschichte von Elfi grendene publizierte
meldete sich auch Irma frei die
Geschichten der beiden Frauen setzten
eine große Recherche in
Gang das Buch Schweiz Arbeiterinnen von
Demut
erscheint da hätte sich Irma frei ein
Zeichen der bürleerben
gewünscht
kein V deine bürleerbe h sich je
entschuldiget denn mir sind ja nur
billige
arbeitskräft wo ausgenüzt wde sind über
60 Jahre hat ir frei ihre Geschichte
verdrängt dann zum ersten Mal ihre Akten
es ist schlimm geseh ich hab mindestens
zwei Wochen lang nicht könen
schlafen das ist so schlimm gie was dir
alles geschrieben hab in den Akten
in so als ob es normals V der Welt
wä aber alles
verlogen es ist nicht so
erst in den Akten sieht sie dass ihre
Mutter immer wieder versucht hat sie
nach Hause zu
[Musik]
holen komme nun nochmals auf mein
letztes schreiben zurück und wollte nun
höflich anfragen wie es steht mit der
heimnah von dem Kind
Irma sie haben ja nun das letzte Mal
Einsicht in unseren Haushalt
gehabt wir auf Weihnachten zu uns nach
Hause holen
möchten wenn ich das früher noch gewüst
h dann hätte ich bestimmt ein anderes
Verhaltnis zu meiner
[Musik]
Mutter won ich entl wurde B da hab ich
ganze 50 Franken über für die D jah ich
geschafft
habberin s fürs zugbillett und ich soll
s zu dem Geld das m lange bis ich in der
Freiheit mE erst Lohn
überk wenn ich h drüber n danke ist das
ein Hohn so
[Musik]
bis ich hab mir eigentlich immer vor gen
du musst stark se so überlst du n ich w
all den wo Gesit du bist n du wir n und
das dir g nicht bewiesen dass sie
fsch Erma frei hat als Model gearbeitet
und sich auf diese Weise Abendkurse
finanziert sie lernte Schreibmaschine
schreiben und arbeitete in der
Buchhaltung mit 24 heiratete sie das
erste
[Musik]
mal gerne hätte sie eine Lehrer als
Damenschneiderin gemacht damals für ein
Heimkind
undenkbar und
ich ich denkt l alles hinter dir es
brauch kein Mensch
zwis was ich für
jug darum
ich habeer man mE Kinder je verzählt und
wenn Mine Kinder gefragt m was hast du
gemacht in der Jugend da ich immer
gesagt Kinder ich habe kein schöne Kind
und kein schöne Jugend ich will nicht da
drüber
reden ir vor z Jahr er
was Sache
[Musik]
ist
wenigerz immer
me in ich da guckt und bin total trrig
in mich versunken und denkt UI nein das
das überhaupt
gibt und vor allem dass das mit Mami
passiert ist das mi mi das hat müsen
ertragen das Leid und dann
hab dann hat mfangen also das er mal
richtig PR und hat mich Arm und ich GB
so wie der ganz Schmerz und Frust und
einfach alles so abgefallen von ih dass
sie dass sie endlich könen drüber
schrieben und reden und machen will sie
das jahrz lang nie gemacht hat und ich
hat den so wenn das ganz blöd
erstms M M M zeigt Emotionen irgend vor
puzel und irgendwis Teile F und wir
wissen nicht genau was ist das es ist so
wie Schwarzeck irgendwie und der
schwarzecken ist jetzt gefüllt Word das
Puzzel ist jetzt komplett und m Verst
fühle spürre das ich B der Mutter
eigentlich will ich immer
dan ja ja richtig ich
immeruck zwischenutter und
Tochter
[Musik]
hallo im Schauspielhaus Zürich Regisseur
Milo rau hat Irma frei für sein Stück
tell als leihendarstellerin engagiert
ein schönen guten Abend meine Damen und
Herren jetzt ist 19:3
minut grüß Dich mein
lieber und
he dich bra ich genau du Gehör das Stu
da ich gagt was h das mit Wilhelm
du jeder wo schlimms erlt hat ist im Le
hät gern so ein tell wo würde befrei und
du h sicher auch gerne wo
dich aus dem Heim und der
Zwangs ja das
stimmt und genau das musst du
[Musik]
verzäh Tonprobe vor der Aufführung die
wenig WS dass der B der 60 J
Zwangsarbeiterin in der Schwiz
beschäftiget hat ich B eine von
den
okay
[Musik]
nach jeder vorstellig ist es mir ein
Stück besser
gangen ich bin froh und ich bin auch
erlichtert dass ich endlich loswen
[Musik]
bin es kommt spat es kommt sehr spat
aber ich bin froh dass man jetzt
überhaupt abacket und noch betroffen GT
was
Erle als
Kommissionspräsident freue ich mich dass
Einstimmigkeit gelungen
ist
[Musik]
emer die hisorische
Aufarbeitung Opfer von Zwangsmaßnahmen
einen Solidaritätsbeitrag von 25 000
Franken Betroffene aus anderen Kantonen
und Gemeinden müssen sich weiter
gedulden
Elfi grendene hat das Geld inzwischen
[Musik]
erhalten ich möchte sagen dass ich
schoh das ist eigentlich wie sparbüch
das haben wir jetzt auf
sparbü jetzt kom es
[Musik]
Bren es ist jetzt einfach Schluss ich
will n wssen von der ganze
Sache
das ist noch der schönste Moment vor
[Musik]
allemchen schöne
Schrift tut weh
verbrennen
Abschied hoffe ich da noch warm über
geschrieben
h jetzt got and
[Musik]
slpp bin ichich alt und frach worden
ja